olá muito prazer eu sou a rua
a maioria das pessoas acredita que viver
na rua é uma opção mas muitas vezes é
uma dificuldade de encontrar um outro
caminho a no inverno de 2015 eu tive uma
gripe o rosa doce há muito assim aquelas
coisas que te de roupa né
eu estava sozinha em casa desse fui
comprar um apartamento foi no bonfim
fui comprar remédio e suco de laranja
quando eu voltei eu encontrei um morador
de rua que é meu vizinho com os mesmos
sintomas e fiquei assim se chocado no
exigente como a gente é igual e não é
aquela gente boa não de verdade
bateu uma coisa lá dentro disse que é
impossível a gente continuar nesse
processo sem enxergar aí vêm os nossos
novos olhares né eu dividimos isso com
ele eu comecei realmente até o despertar
interna assim e nem se despertar eu
comecei a fazer meditação a pensar
enquanto começa a olhar para dentro de
si vai enxergando o outro com mais
clareza neto começa a enxergar que não é
o teu umbigo e nisso um dia numa rede
social e serão novembro de 2015 eu
conheci uma página um cara chamado
carlos lacerda que é do interior da
bahia ele criou o banho solidário na
hora na madrugada teve uma crise
compulsiva de choro exigente é isso isso
que eu quero trazer para porto alegre e
parte da minha história bateu dentro do
coração
no outro dia de manhã eu liguei pra ele
e de qual time manda como é que eu faço
esse desenho como é que ele não tinha
nada muito escrito assim só umas
explicações básicas e eu comecei a jogar
nem se nessa sensação um isso eu tinha
muito boa vontade nem um tostão
procurei e escrevi o projeto de
fevereiro de 2016
o projeto estava pronto aí eu comecei a
criar um cão fã dele aí tem que achar o
dinheiro
três amigas que foram os únicos que
ditaram o projeto todo mundo achava uma
loucura portava vocês vocês vão te pegar
os moradores de rua né
e na realidade é a quando quando é te
ver se começo a maria velha tática foram
as que saíram para a rua comigo porque a
gente foi entrevistar a perguntar pra
ele se eles realmente queriam o local
mais fácil de utilização do mãe
aí quando o final de março de 2016 e
pronto não vai dar né porque a descrença
era muito grande a gente estava no
momento super conturbado do país
então assim eu disse olha é preciso
ajude apareceram mais duas mulheres
márcia e marilei que são assim agradeço
até hoje elas que foram que mexeram na
realidade com o processo terminou bem
solidário ea gente conseguiu 20 mil e
quatrocentos reais a gente precisava de
20 mil então gente em três meses seis
mulheres meio doidas nem acreditando
numa ideia conseguiram fazer alguma
coisa virar realidade é a questão da
ação olhar a acreditar e fazer né
o primeiro banho amanhã faz um ano e
banho foi de 11 11 de junho de 2016 está
a nossa ideia era fazer um dia antes do
dia dos namorados para ser um dia de
amor justo amor de justiça e inclusão
social está a e o banho não falei como é
que ele é um reboque adaptado com
chuveiro dos dois lados masculino e
feminino chuveiro quente de juncker
melhor do que a minha casa posso
garantir gente tá a ea gente para um
lugar de grande movimento de pessoas
agente da roupa lanche material gene paz
como evidente a idéia que eles enxergam
em um grande processo do banho a idéia
do cláudio que é o pai de todos os
bancos do brasil é isso é que ele se
olhem a gente botou um espelho depois
ali
a idéia é que faltem mais de mil pessoas
que se olharam naquele espelho e
pensaram como eu estou bonito como eu
estou bem
a frase que a gente mais ouve assim
agora eu sou gente agora eu consigo
agora eu também né olhar sim
esse foi o primeiro banho oito pessoas a
gente já teve até 60 pessoas atendidas
está o que o banho trouxe foi a
visibilidade ou seja essas pessoas
sempre existir ela estava nos guetos
embaixo das pontes dos viadutos elas
sempre estiveram por aqui é que a gente
fingia que
não via na realidade né todos os dias a
gente vê os corpos deles surge ignorados
e abandonadas e eu vejo tenho certeza
que todo mundo vem a gente dá uma pensar
dinha ea gente tem uma questão muito
séria que a questão estatística feijão
tem idéia da quantidade disso segundo
ano passado a universidade federal do
rio grande do sul ufrgs fez contratado
pela fasc a fundação de assistência
social do município de porto alegre
um estudo com os moradores de rua nós
temos 2.115 moradores em situação de rua
355 vagas em albergues a conta não fecha
tá e a gente tem 1700 pessoas que dormem
ao relento ou escondido em algum buraco
todos os dias são quatro auditórios que
nem é esse aqui de gente dormir na rua
ea grande questão no mundial poder
portuguesa que poder público gente olha
um país que a gente está a nossa
proposta é a gente como sociedade civil
acordado despertar para esse processo
não dá pra negar fingir que não está
acontecendo tacin ea grande questão é
que é possível sim a no dia do banho por
dia 7 graus tá como hoje de manhã ea
gente teve uma grande visibilidade às
pessoas começaram realmente acreditar e
nessas estatísticas gente nos últimos
cinco anos cresceu 57% da população de
rua em porto alegre é galopante a gente
tem 10 11 por cento por ano de
crescimento e não é assim a para eles
não é pra gente
a cidade está cada vez mais pesado as
pessoas estão cada vez mais mas e
tristes ea grande questão é se olhar um
sorriso é considerá los como parte do
processo tá é o que a gente mais ouve é
tirar esse cara da minha porta a porta
do meu prédio
não tenho nada pra te dar e aí vem é não
dá nada não dá a empatia que eu quero no
entanto falou em outros em outros
prédios né não enxergá los como parte do
nosso processo a gente conversa com eles
o banho tem um processo que é de falar a
gente não trata a eles aos coitadinhos
não ajustada eles como gente como a
gente porque são gente como a gente é a
gente descobriu que uma parte deles são
trabalhadores efetivos ele está
patinhas resíduos recicláveis lavam
carros ou são vendedores ambulantes a
eles têm um trabalho isso não é uma 30
40% da parcela da população e tem a
questão das drogas ea gente ouve uma
coisa muito séria é em x custa r$10 e
mata fome por duas horas
uma pedra de crack custa 5 e não se
pensa em comida em seis horas
assim a fome o frio a situação de ruas
desumanizam completamente muito pode
esperar que venha alguém touch eles mais
um problema o problema é nosso também
como sociedade civil
no momento que não é cobrar dos outros
não na hora que dei um sorriso para
tratar é melhor ele vai tratar melhor na
rua tem tem isso eles são como a gente a
o banho
a gente está toda a gente tem a parte de
escovação isso que eu quero mostrar para
vocês eles enxergam ele se a gente dá
comida lanche material de higiene e
conversa aí depois eles para ficar
tomando cafezinho e ficamos quatro horas
ou vindos mas não do passado mas o que
eles pensam e querem ser eles também
charles também olham o futuro gente a
gente deveria olhar o futuro talvez até
como eles assim porque eles ainda tem a
questão da esperança no momento que eles
saem de lá eles têm esperança a quero
que vocês conhecem o seu valdir o seu
valdir é um trabalho que a gente fez um
banho solidário com o ação rua calábria
que é uma entidade de uma ong que trata
dos moradores mas eles não conseguiram
tanto acesso a eles por quiser mais
desconfiados como a gente não é uma ong
a gente é uma galera da sociedade civil
sem fins lucrativos religiosos nem
políticos a gente está querendo fazer o
bem pelo bem como disse cláudio lacerda
a gente não tem juízo de valor nem
julgamento a gente não tem condições não
se fazer nada chegou até a tomar banho
recomenda beleza não tem problema em seu
direito foi o primeiro banho se vocês
vissem o estado daquela calça jeans
vocês não têm idéia do que era saiu
assim durinha pelo lixo
aí ele foi vendo as pessoas foram
conversando e tentando entender que ele
era e se esse é o seu valdir no segundo
banho no terceiro banco a gente já
conseguiu a cortar o cabelo ea gente
leva às vezes cabeleireiro nem sempre
quem quiser cabeleireiro quisermos
ajudar na frente de vez em quando
aparece cabeleira gente conta
cabelo fez a barba aqui ele já estava
começando a pensar em ir para casa
porque é um retorno também há o processo
aqui então aqui ele quando nos visitou
já de banho tomado na casa nova e essa é
a casa de seo valdir
a grande questão o que a gente percebeu
que a gente conclamo as pessoas a gente
está falando a verdade novos olhares é
as pessoas precisam que a gente nota que
não tem nenhum trabalho emocional
psicológico quando eles saem das ruas e
não é uma coisa tem que uma pessoa
especializada não a gente tem muita
dificuldade de se conectar com eles né
então e como a sociedade civil se a
gente começar a olhar para eles e
começar a se preocupar realmente o que
nós podemos fazer no dia a dia para
ajudar várias pessoas de voto uma pessoa
em situação de rua detalhe é pessoa
apenas o politicamente correto é pessoas
em situação de rua mas quando a gente
olha eu convivi com eles são moradores
de rua sim gente não tem lugar para eles
morarem a questão do ganha um salário
mínimo não tem nenhuma escolaridade isso
não consegue um trabalho melhor como
aonde isso vai morar porque o prato é um
cidadão tem que ter endereço rg cpf
carteira de trabalho para o cidadão
normal tá difícil conseguir emprego
então a grande questão é como nós como
sociedade civil falando de tudo que o
pessoal falou antes do tek como nós
vamos achar soluções específicas para
isso como a menina das ciências falou
como a menina da dislexia como todo
mundo está falando ou seja gente parte
do nosso processo interno
um dia a gente resolveu dá voz a eles e
eles nos contaram
ele escreveu eu quero parar com as
drogas esse menino chegou e pediu eu
quero a gente ouviu na realidade aí vem
tem que achar graham altos espaço que eu
consegui botar todas essas pessoas em
situação de rua para terem um tratamento
a gente descobriu a criatividade ea
gente descobrir uma poesia uma poetisa
no meio da rua
essa carinha e brandão eu queria falar
para vocês antes de contar um pouco mais
de carinho que nesses 12 meses assim a
gente conseguiu tirar o encaminhado de
volta para a família e voltar para casa
ou se internar doze pessoas não seria
assim uma pessoa por mês
gente a gente medo de mulher é meio
doido agora tem apareceram os homens
para ajudar e se tivesse mais como a
gente
né assim quero compartilhar com vocês a
poesia da carinha ela escreveu nesse dia
sentadinha naquela foto que vocês estão
vendo liberdade de expressão não é um
papel na mão mas o poder da voz nação
custos dramas lágrimas dor de uma pobre
senhora trás de seu filho que está
perdido no mundo nesse mundo sujo os
ricos têm uma idéia errada sobre os
moradores de rua por também ser humanos
e com o coração todos somos iguais
iguais a vocês que têm carro mansão
todos temos sonhos e desejos só não
temos casa então como vocês têm uma tira
um dia das suas luxuosas vidas e veio
falar com a gente e assim vocês vão
entender e nos conhecer melhor
prazer eu sou a rua ea esperança de
todos
para brandão eles moradores em situação
de rua do viaduto da borges de medeiros
muito prazer
agora não sou eu a rua agora somos todos
nós
[Aplausos]